all right let's do it baby it's down to
game on game on baby
yes major coming in baby for the blue
ball from shale town on the Qt pot gets
it it is a beast on Thresh yesterday
yesterday all my troubles seemed so far
on you can also have started up on
fairness TSM and the nice concave they
can't only percent it gets gonna get on
the Tyra stone they try to exploit him
he gets g8 right there crumbs low at HP
they jump in a while Colonel Stark I'm
seriously looking to kill the well so
yes they do Landers not come in time
goober wants to Barbara Dignitas ready
for smack uses his own his expression to
come out now getting my soul of trying
to run away
getting somebody with the barrier I was
trying to make it happen still turning
on the cutie pie what is the guy
survives and get bit expression doesn't
land to play either he is alone he will
not kill him a cutie pie huge team
beiping up there for Dignitas need light
is to be caught a load of failed to
flash over the wall this is not good
flood waters gonna be nearby uh-oh
the counter of bag odds and zouna that
was beautiful sorry he did not fail his
class he saved that for visit move right
here decide not fit next victim is most
likely going to be nice but they're
trying to run him down cutie pie cutie
pies got one cutie pies life skills is
it meant the Tenjin needs to rebelled
that's a car you get the roses jumper -
is back with dr. troubles cutie pie goes
huge foot dick Nixon Bank Bowl but
students Punk pity fights big ad the
Baron quick shot they destroyed go
Scooby go for broke here Dignitas is
gonna be in big QE k dance
cutie pie think of his damn sexy cute by
himself on the back line that was Krong
to kiwi-kid on fortune
- damage caused the beginning Oh gamma
cutie-pie gone crazy picks up one gets
the reset has a chance to get out of
this one lately they're going for shift
to the Bob will not taking it down
that's a triple kill but there's been
happening for the LG a bit of a medicine
now things tied Linna chol how do you
rank current ad season LCS best to where
it's ordering yourself amongst them
they'll [ __ ] garbage did I put myself
top 5 at least everyone else [ __ ] in
the trash it doesn't matter he's [ __ ]
top 5 I'm top 5 and I'm probably better
than everyone so this all that matters
you need to keep your knees straight
Michael this is what separates a pro
player from the lesser player average
blade is 3 gold for 10 seconds so in my
desk I can make nine gold so yeah I'm
not going to upgrade it until I make
that 9 goes I'm not going to make it
static sue telling you the small things
like that that people take for granted
why why you talking like a loser
because I am losing not you know who's a
loser double it you think you're SS no I
have a little more nerdy to my fans on
TSM no oh [ __ ] oh my god did Wow I'll
find someone new Z please swing from a
tabletop heart is for Santa if you send
me a pizza man I love you
Wow someone actually bought me a pizza
whoever that is whoever that isn't the
chat man god bless you and however the
[ __ ] you figured out my extra cookies
got to Israel forget a pentakill here is
what I'm askin can I get a pentakill
here is what I'm askin can I get a
pentakill here is what I'm askin looks
like I can woo
Oh baby oh [ __ ]
yes flash red Chabad come on
yeah I'm here with you I'm here with you
it's my pent-up Beijing betta oh my god
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] god how did I live there
you think you get away from me to cook
oh my god holy [ __ ] alright saver is
broken like a dick
I'm coming actually yeah I can probably
clean this up
no flash shut oh your [ __ ] dick oh
let's go
oh my god holy [ __ ] I thought I had I
had my [ __ ] finger on the rocks here
got the
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how you doing
that's me dude I'm a cutie pie thanks
for watching if you want more great
content be sure to hit that subscribe
button
[Music]